occasionally I do videos that are
to some sort of question that a viewer
or sometimes a student will ask me that
I think are particularly interesting
that I can get a lot of mileage out of
so to speak and which I think might
might be helpful for other people and
I've got a question that's being asked
to me by one of my my subscribers who
often comments on my videos and it has
to do with with anger which which is
something that I've given a lot of
thought to and have a lot of experience
with Annie he asks I know that you've
done some videos about Aristotle's views
on anger but I realized that it's an
area you've done a lot of study in
recently I've been having some of my own
troubles with anger so I was wondering
if it would be possible at some time you
could do a more personal video about
your experiences with anger and what you
have learned in your studies and if
there's more to it than that but I think
actually that in order to adequately
respond to this it's probably going to
take more than one one video even as
long as my videos tend to be so I think
what I want to talk about in this one
I'll mention a few of my own personal
experiences with anger and why I'm so
particularly interested in it as a
philosophical topic but then I'll also
talk about much more about the resources
that I found in a philosophy and also to
a certain extent in in theology and in
psychotherapeutic theory about how to
make sense of it and thereby adding to
it some some you know work on my part
what for me allowed me to become a less
angry person and to have better
understanding of control over my own
anger which might be useful for other
people I'm not saying that there's a
one-size-fits-all solution to this so I
have been a very angry person throughout
my life
if there is anything like a genuine and
untrue theory of temperaments I am
definitely a choleric meaning somebody
who tends to take offense rather easily
to get angry and really an enlarged
respect I'm not one of the good coal
Erichs I've had for a long time a
tendency to hold on to anger to develop
grudges to to act on them and it's only
I would say in the last 10 years of my
life out of you know them in my 40s that
I've been able to make much progress
that and a large part of that consisted
in seeing just how counterproductive and
and ultimately useless a lot of what I
was engaged in was was for me and you
know how hurtful it was to other people
around me so you know I'll talk in
another video I think about some of my
my own experiences with this but I will
say this I you know my anger lied to me
when I was a kid getting into a lot of
fights and feeling bad a lot of the time
it went so far as to result in me when I
was 16 years old becoming a ward of the
court because my my mother by that's
when my dad had died and there were all
sorts of things surrounding that filed
an uncontrollability petition with with
the court because I was I was out of
control and I was getting in quite a bit
of trouble and a lot of that had to do
with my my own inability to to
understand and manage my own anger I
would say that I've managed if not
necessarily to ruin at least to screw up
and then have to do a lot of damage
control afterwards a lot of
relationships
because of my my responsive anger and I
think there's opportunities that I've
passed up or which I threw away because
of because of getting angry that would
have placed me further along in in my
career or even maybe resulted in doing a
different kind of thing
I still struggle quite a bit with anger
really The Closer that a person is to me
the more vulnerable I am to getting you
know getting hurt and angry in response
to things that they do which is actually
an improvement because you know I used
to get angry with students and I it
doesn't happen too much anymore unless
they're you know really engaging an
egregious behavior you know like
plagiarizing and then telling me that
they didn't plagiarize and that it's
okay and that sort of thing but I still
have I still have a lot to do and a lot
of a lot of ground to cover when it
comes to my my intimate personal
relationships yeah and getting getting
better and better control on on my anger
and I'm a person who thinks that anger
is not something that we want to
eliminate altogether I agree with the
philosophers who like Aristotle and
Thomas Aquinas who think that anger has
a legitimate function and scope and that
the real challenge is to figure out what
that is because we're usually wrong in
the way that we see it and then to you
know realign the self and its its
responses and desires and thoughts and
attitudes to be more in line with right
anger so all that said and again I'll
probably shoot another video some other
time about you know anger in my life you
know all the difference but not all the
different positive occasions where we're
getting angry
you know the wrong idea and perhaps
where I got some like wrongheaded ideas
about anger from because we we really do
belong to a culture that is totally
screwed up with respect to anger and you
get the wrong message as as a kid and as
an a young adult and as a continuing
adult over and over and over again
through all sorts of means so you know
really if you don't end up having anger
problems you're kind of lucky or you
know you won't you you're fortunate
enough to be in a household that already
had a mentor who can you know train you
right or maybe you had the kind of
disposition that didn't get angry and
kind of let things go which would be
kind of nice anyway what I want to talk
about are I would say like somewhere
from five to seven or eight thinkers who
study of whom has really helped me to to
better understand the way anger works
and why I get angry and what I get angry
about and whether I'm getting angry for
the right reason and how to how to get
myself out of that how to dig myself out
of the pit that anger often be becomes
and how to avoid letting it congeal into
things that are that are much worse you
know sort of collaborating with the
worst parts of ourselves so I'm not
going to present these thinkers like in
the order that I started you know
thinking through them all the students
kind of a sequential order as far as
their their time where they fit into the
philosophical timeline I would say that
one of the thinkers who I've learned
quite a bit from even though he doesn't
have a systematic account of anger as
such is Plato and Plato's discussions of
anger are kind of scattered across his
works one of the really important things
that I came into contact with
was his discussion in in the the
Republic about parts of the soul or if
you don't like the word soul say
personality and the way he's got it the
human being has the this rational part
that when it's functioning right it
contains wisdom as a virtue and reasons
out the way one ought to live what would
be good for oneself and what would be
right and just and that part is is the
highest part of our self but it's also
relatively vulnerable to being used by
the lower parts and the lowest part is
the appetites and these are multiple and
they're they're very strong in human
beings and therefore all sorts of things
like sacs are for food you know for
money because money can buy us these
these sorts of things for pleasures of
all all different sorts and then there's
this middle part that Plato calls
themost and it's sometimes translated as
spirit or passion neither of which are
very good good translations and the word
themost can actually mean anger Plato
defines it as the part with which we get
angry this middle part is also the locus
for the virtue of courage or of
cowardice and there's a connection
between anger and courage because if you
think about when you get angry you are
very often placed in a situation that
you feel to be a conflict and to be
angry can provide you with the impetus
that you need in order to be courageous
but it's kind of its kind of mercurial
to be angry is not quite the same thing
over to be under the control of angers
not quite the same thing as to actually
have an exercise the virtue of courage
this middle part through most is
required in order for the rational part
to rule over the appetites in the city
it corresponds to the auxiliaries that
the police force the army that are
needed to get the unruly citizenry who
would be motivated just by their
their desires to actually obey the
dictates of the the higher the better
part and yeah I think there's something
to that that view this this middle part
is also the part of us that is
particularly concerned with honor with
our view of our self and with how others
view us and if you think about it when
we get angry very often it's because we
feel there's some sort of violation of
our our dignity our honor what what is
expected by us of other people or at
least perceived to be so and another
thing that Plato says that's
particularly important I think is he
talks about he does this in several
different dialogues what are the things
that we get angry at each other about
when we get into disagreements about and
it's not really so much you know just
just factual matters like who did what
and you know or how much money is there
the till or things like that we can get
mad at each other over those sorts of
things but if it's just a merely factual
question it's pretty easily you know
addressed and you know we can we can
deal with it and if somebody wants to be
really stubborn they can continue to be
you know angry and fight about it but
but usually if they're at all reasonable
you can say look there's you know five
dollars left let's count it well we get
angry about our the realm of of what we
can call values and disagreements with
each other on values and even though we
can make cases to each other why
something has the value it has or why
you know somebody else should see it
this way we often don't convince each
other and and Plato goes so far as to
say it's not just human beings that to
get angry with each other and fight with
each other on account of these things
it's even the gods the Greek gods don't
see eye to eye on matters of goodness
and badness in its various modalities
which include in particular the just and
the unjust the advantageous or
beneficial and the harm
and most importantly the noble or
honorable and the the base or or ugly or
dishonorable so cologne and tow ice
chrome and we're liable to get angry
over over these things in part because
we we feel them so deeply and you know
you might say well then that we should
reduce get away from from values values
are purely subjective and you know we
don't want to get into that that's not
the route that Plato takes and that's
what I love about Plato
hey I'm you know I'll say this it makes
me angry and I actually don't like
people who say oh it's values are all
subjective and it's just in the eye of
the beholder for the ancient Greeks at
least and the medievals there is a
subjectivity to it but some people are
wrong and some people are right and and
that's not to say that we always know
exactly what's right but we sure as hell
need to work towards it and when we're
actually right one way in which we can
tell is we're actually aligned with
other people who've got it right and
it's it's easy to get angry in this
process Plato would point out Plato also
seems to think that we have some
legitimate role for anger in our lives
and he doesn't quite spell this out and
I think if you if you had to push him
when it comes to the legitimate scope
and role for anger he would say it's
probably narrow narrower than somebody
like Aristotle would say so another
person that's really important in my
thinking about anger is Aristotle and
Aristotle doesn't have a treatise on
anger but Aristotle has a very complex
systematically worked out very you know
sophisticated but yet still skeletal
theory of anger running through his
works and you can find it in the
rhetoric and in the ethics
nikka McCain and you Damian in parts of
the politics in parts of you know on the
soul in the topics in some of the physic
treatises you know it in mentions in on
memory and on dreams it's it's brought
up over and over and over again he uses
it as one of the most common examples
for quite a few things and he tells us a
lot about anger in the process and one
of the things that I found very useful
Aristotle tells us that one of the main
causes of anger for us is the perception
on our part that we are being wronged by
by another person that is that they're
doing some some harm to us and they're
doing it wrongly they're doing you know
he says that when were punished and we
actually think we deserve the punishment
we don't get angry it's when we think
that we don't deserve the way that we're
being treated and the way that he's
being treated he calls Oh Liguria or
slidin literally a making little and he
calls this a sort of what should we call
it
you know activation or manifestation
holding another in in low esteem of
thinking little of them and the role
that appearance plays for Aristotle is
very important not only in in causing
anger but also in our desire our desire
is to impose retribution Timoner ASUS on
the other person and he uses the same
term apparent phenomena for that as well
and that can mean public or that could
mean a parent or that could mean even
something like in our imagination so you
know Aristotle's attuned to a lot of
important aspects of anger and he's got
this whole discussion of how it comes
about and the various you know common
modes in which it comes about and who we
tend to get more angry when were you
know in the presence of and who we tend
to become more calm in relation
- so all these exacerbating factors
Aristotle was attentive to these and his
theory doesn't cover everything there's
some things where where you know you
read it and on its surface you're like
no I think you got that wrong but most
of the stuff he seems to be pretty right
and Aristotle thinks that there is there
are times when we should be angry there
are people who should be angry with
there are matters about which we should
be angry we tend to go too far to the to
the extreme you know to the extreme of
too much getting too angry getting angry
at too many people rather than the
person that we're actually angry at
holding on to our anger for too long and
not being as forgiving as we ought to be
but Aristotle thinks there are some
things that shouldn't be forgiven and he
thinks that there are some there are
some cases of our being belittled or
pushed around then we ought to get angry
at and that it's good for us to do so
and it would be actually bad on the
other side for us not to do so to not
stand up for ourselves or not to stand
up for those who are connected with us
you know in my case like for example my
children I should get mad yeah a teacher
who unjustly assigns bad grades to my
kids
and then you know won't listen to reason
that would be a case where Aristotle
would think that would be would be quite
legitimate but Aristotle's one about
measure and proportion so that's that's
something good and he's very focused on
how do we change our our feelings and
our attitudes in our behavior it has to
do with how we choose to use that little
bit of freedom that we have in actual
situations where we find ourselves and
the notes that anger is one of those
emotions it tends to get away from us
we're subject to being what he calls a
kradic that is to lose our self-control
and to be led around by the kind of
reasoning that is endemic to
to anger which is kind of a reason light
or pseudo reasoning not really
rationality functioning and it's at its
highest so I'll tell you how for me
thinking through these things really
helped me out in in real situations
now another thinker that has been really
influential on my own attitudes towards
these these matters is Epictetus and
epictetus goes further he doesn't think
that that's ever good to be angry but he
he does at least tell you here's what's
going on when you do get angry and
here's here's you know what happens
every time that you choose to give in to
it he actually talks about it as being
sort of like opening up old wounds and
why why would you want to do that to
yourself and he gives us counsel about
how to understand not only our owning or
but other people's anger and how not to
let their anger get to us one of the
things that anger tends to do is to
provoke more anger in return because if
I get angry at you and you don't feel
like I should be getting angry at you
then I'm treating you in a way that that
you feel is unfair and kind of like
putting you down in a certain way and
then you get angry at me who are you to
get angry at me over this you know who
are you to complain this is very very
common and epictetus is really good at
saying look other people are not going
to be completely rational hell you're
not even completely rational yourself
and you're trying so you got to be a bit
more understanding of them and try not
to like you know say that what they're
doing is okay but try to see things
their way and you will actually find
yourself being less angry with them and
if you're gonna feel anything it'll be
more like feeling sorry for them because
they're they're so screwed up that they
can't help but get angry over over
trivial stuff so you know and with
epictetus there's also as there was with
Aristotle and and also with plate of it
with Epictetus a lot more systematically
spelled out
how do I change my attitudes my behavior
my habits he goes more into detail on
that so I found him very useful
I reject Epictetus rejection of anger
wholesale I'm more of a stew Tilly in
that way but I think that he has a lot
of great advice to contribute the next
person who I would say that I draw on
and I'm getting more and more interested
in would be Saint Augustine and
Augustine if you had to pick where does
he fall in with anger he's more like
Plato you know closer to somebody like
Epictetus further away from aristotle he
does think that there can be legitimate
times for us to be angry but it's very
rare and we got to be really really
careful because what does anger have a
tendency to turn into into hatred and
hatred is is something that bores into
our soul and it's much harder to get out
Aristotle actually distinguish between
anger and hatred by saying that that
anger is something that is sort of
curable and and hatred you know really
to a large extent isn't hatred desires
for the hated person not even to exist
just to be like not be in this universe
anger wants to hurt the other person
because it feels you know wrong but it
doesn't go anywhere near where hatred
does an aerosol didn't look at the
relationship between these Augustine
sees that anger can really easily if
it's not dealt with properly congeal
into hatred and now it becomes much more
dangerous anger can also turn into these
you know very vicious dispositions that
we call wrath and Augustine himself
doesn't talk about you know the eight
capital vices or the seven deadly sins
the way a lot of other Christian
thinkers will do but he's very conscious
of of how detrimental anger
be at the same time he he doesn't say
you should never ever ever get angry the
way that some Christian thinkers would
do and he's it's interesting because
there's certain once Christianity enters
onto the scene there's certain biblical
verses particularly from the Sermon on
the Mount where it's a question how do
you interpret this you know if if it's
wrong to get angry at your brother does
I mean it's always wrong to being angry
at your brother this this thing about
calling your brother raca or fool how
bad is that and Augustine takes the
position that well it's not as bad as
some things but it's pretty bad so you
really want to pull that that thorn out
of your self of anger another person
who's really instrumental for me is
another Christian thinker a monk called
John Cassian and what casseon what his
works consistent is is largely taking
the wisdom that was communicated to him
from the Egyptian desert fathers because
he went he he was a monk and he went
around with this friend of his who was
also a monk and first he wants Palestine
and then he went into the Egyptian
desert and he'd spend time with these
these these monks were living in the
egyptian desert who were struggling with
anger problems
honest to god i mean you know some of
the stuff that he says is so brilliant
like well you can go out to the desert
but unless you actually deal with your
anger problems you're gonna find
yourself like getting angry with the
stones and you know unless you unless
you change your character and to do that
is going to require some sort of you
know some help from from from a bob
because because you're pretty screwed up
you have to contribute your own part to
it as well for for cassian unless you
unless you do that your anger isn't
going to go away and he's one of the
people who
who starts writing he's not the first
guy but he but he takes up this notion
of the eight capital vices that these
Desert Fathers were thinking about one
of these is wrath or gay which is the
Greek word for anger and it goes into a
lot of detail you know he's drawing on
the experience that these guys had
different ways we get angry and how we
justify it to ourselves and how we do
you know we do things that are good
things but we do it because we're gonna
stick it to that guy over there like
fasting for example you know if you fast
on anger it's not it's not a good fast
it's actually harmful to you in his view
other he talks about ways in which
people are without using this term
passive-aggressive with each other in
terms of their anger where forgiveness
might not be real forgiveness you know
and so I find his analyses particularly
good in part because you know I'm an
angry person when I see some of these
things applying to me these Desert
Fathers really understood human nature
well you know and so cassian is drawing
on their wisdom and then I suppose the
next person I would talk about would be
Thomas Aquinas and Thomas has has
discussions of anger he doesn't have a
treaty son anger he deals with it
largely in terms of the passions and
also in terms of you know the the vices
and virtues and also in terms of the
seven deadly sins which are you know
what the eight capital vice has become
as they get transformed in Western
Christianity through largely through the
intermediary of Gregory the Great Smog
job for Thomas anger you know he's
Aristotelian in this sense anger has a
legitimate role in fact its job is to
help us attain what he calls the
difficult good you know there's there's
goods that are easy to obtain and then
there's goods that are kind of like you
know threatened and so you know sticking
up for my kids again getting angry and
sticking up for them that would be if
I'm doing it right ly attaining the
difficult good so he's very attentive to
the legitimate you know scope that anger
would have and he's drawing on Aristotle
but he's also drawing on Christian
tradition to make sense of this and he
gives us a lot of quite powerful tools
you know he talks about the the
daughters of anger you know what are the
different roles and enough roles but
what are the different forms that anger
takes and when we do that sort of thing
it helps us to identify I've got a
problem with this one over here and why
do I have a problem with that what sort
of assumptions am I making that lead me
to you know think that person is my
enemy and I have to I have to hurt them
or I have to like you know feel this
this feeling of anger towards them so at
this point in my my development and at
this point in my studies I would say
those are the six thinkers that I have
found most illuminating in their
discussions of anger the ones that I
found the most helpful I've you know
done work on a lot of other people on
anger you know particularly modern
thinkers like Rene Descartes and Thomas
Hobbes and Jeremy Bentham and they tend
to treat anger I feel in rather
reductive ways that don't do don't do
justice to what's actually going on when
we feel angry I think the ancients and
the medievals for the most part
understood anger better than many of the
modern theorists do the exception to
that would be I would say somebody like
dietrich von Hildebrand
I very much like his discussion of anger
in his his works but he was attentive to
through the role of emotions and
activity and he sees he's it's
interesting because he he sees anger as
something that is somewhat different
from the other emotions and doesn't tie
into the the highest parts of ourselves
so it's not it's not as revelatory of
things as love could be but it's not
it's not you know bad in the same way
that pride and concur pissants and
hatred are so I'm you know I find that
attractive as well there's I have a lot
more to do in my studies on anger
particularly as I want to write on on
this but you know a level with you
a lot of what I need to do is be more
consistent in applying this stuff to my
own life and particularly with those
with whom I'm close that's the biggest
set of challenges for me I don't know
what the the challenge is for any of
those watching this video maybe but
that's that's where that's my greatest
weak area that I need to work on and
these thinkers really do help me to make
sense out of things